[Music]
do you mind watching yourself like you
just watched that clip right now it's
pretty intense are you one of those cuz
I have some actors come on the show and
say I
I can't watch myself and I have some
that enjoy watching themselves a little
too much I might kind of fall into both
categories the first time you watch
something you you slightly just fully
yourself around the screen you know like
so you don't know what the scene is
about you just you're only looking yes
of with you
yeah wise guy how come I don't look like
George Clooney I'd anyway nobody told me
that now I'm curious
I would think we're on a show like that
everybody wants to know what's gonna
happen and you're in social situations
maybe you have a drink or two and people
were trying to get you to slip up and
tell what's going to happen what's it's
a it's a it has been a weird nine months
for that because I either had people
sort of dribbling on me they got so
close to me offering me drinks and
pouring me and stroking me or I would
walk in the room and people would just
leave just fly out in the opposite
direction is that good no no I haven't
seen it yet I haven't seen it yeah don't
tell me don't tell me downtown it
downtown you know there's someone else
right next to me just sort of gang so
what happens at the end of the day so
you know that guy I don't know
conversation with anybody that's what's
crazy too is that there needs to be a
time limit you have these people that
haven't seen the end they haven't
watched the last episode yet cuz we're
in this DVR generation watch it I
haven't seen it yet yeah but a year
later you say yes watching come in I
know if you can't do that after a year I
got it yeah I know right
exactly it's like it's like the
conversation police yes it's like no let
me talk yeah I want to talk about the
show I saw two years ago yeah I'm sorry
you haven't seen it yet no we've already
just a bump sure we've upset Andy I
don't know if you're all caught up but
no I'm not because of when I'm fine
no but how do you know what what show
yeah no no I know I did not see this
season because we were moving and we
didn't have a TV at the time and then I
just so I let the whole season go by so
this is a big spoiler to me but I'm a
grown-up
yeah yeah I'm gonna get through it I'll
be I think I'll be all right yeah you so
many English actors have been influenced
by one guy Sir Michael Caine and I know
that you're a fan of his as well I've
always liked I always loved Michael
Caine and dreamed about meeting him he's
a legend Mike okay yes sir Michael if
you please yes
yeah so yeah yeah what's the joke it was
the only supposed to blow the bloody
doors off is the end of the Italian Job
but he gave this masterclass in acting
which my entire generation of actors I
think washed which is always always look
at the eye closest to the camera and
don't blink and so a whole generation of
actors just acted like this without
blinking now I'm gonna cry right this is
the famous advice he gave don't blink
yeah just don't blink yeah
so there's if you want if you watch it
if you watch my generation of actors
about ten years ago before we realized
that you can blink
yeah and it's okay is it the one honey
blink it's really fun is it possible
that the sermon came was just saying
that just screw up a whole generation so
he can get all the work exactly because
you know Sir Michael Caine he's just
he's iconic isn't he and he was just he
was a great great film star and he did
have that kind of heavy-lidded you know
very direct gaze so was working for him
maybe was just trying to tell us or to
you know teach us how to be film stars
in his image I I bumped into him once
someplace and he was so great he came
over to me and he just said and I don't
do that's an amazing Michael Caine but
he came over to me and he said he he
looked at me and he said I've got the
sunscreen just for you young and he told
me about this amazing sunscreen yeah
I was so thrilled and I like wrote it
down I'm like I'm gonna get that
sunscreen and then later on I was like
why did he cross a room to tell me but
I'm the whitest thing he's ever seen
yeah yeah